hey how's it going everyone so it is
official
spider-man homecoming 2 has its official
title now that's right we have an
official title to the spider-man sequel
and it is called spider-man far from
home and the leak was given to us by
none other than spider-man himself Tom
Holland that's right Tom Holland himself
has leaked the title for spider-man far
from home Tom took to Instagram to
apologize to his fans for their really
not being any new information released
about the spider-man sequel however he
did tell us that he has finally received
the script and as he says that he's
finally seen the script he sort of holds
it up and in doing so gives us a glimpse
at the title hey guys what's up its all
Molony I am having a great time meaning
everyone it's going really well I wanted
to apologize because there's no real
revelations coming out this weekend
about spider-man 2 I don't know much
about it I'm a little confused because I
died so I don't really know how it all
comes into play but I do know as I've
got the new script I'm super excited to
read it and it's gonna be great
so yeah spider-man soon let's do this so
as you can see here when he holds the
script up we can pretty clearly see the
title it says far from home I also think
it's pretty funny the smirk on Tom's
face as he holds it up he's kind of like
yeah I know I just showed did the title
I kind of did that on purpose you're
welcome
there was a talk a long time ago about a
supposedly for the title that was called
spider-man field trip and now that we
have this official title far from home
some people are saying that well
obviously this elite was fake if they
were saying that the title is called
field trip and we know now that it's
called far from home but that is not
necessarily true the leak could be true
and everything about it could be true
except they may have just changed the
name they've been known to do that it's
hard to kind of settle on a name
especially for a huge movie such as
spider-man and if you think about it the
field trip that the leaks that they were
taking
in a city far away and far from home
well obviously that's indicating that he
is far away as well so I think that this
title still kind of goes with a leak
that we got a couple weeks ago and not
to mention that the writers and the
producers and directors have been known
to give Tom Holland either fake scripts
or not give him the script until right
before he's gonna shoot his scenes
because he tends to sort of link
information like he did in this video so
the title on his script may not even be
real but I actually doubt that I do
think that this is the official title of
the film and I think that they release
this because they haven't given us
anything else about it so again this is
kind of a hey sorry that really nothing
has been said or revealed about it but
here you go here's the title of it we're
giving you something so there you have
it
spider-man far from home what do you all
think of this new title and also where
do you think spider-man far from home
we'll pick up after cuz as Tom Holland
said he dieded the last movie to me this
is just a confirmation that they're
gonna bring them back in Avengers 4 but
let me know what you all think in the
comments below be sure to hit that like
button before you leave and don't forget
to subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on spider-man far from home
Avengers for all things Marvel DC and
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you